para analizar lo que fue este primer día
de temporada está con nosotros desde
bucaramanga Colombia Valentina Peña
periodista de la W radio en ese país
bienvenida Valentina a France 24
Hola qué tal Un saludo para ustedes
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
para tenerme aquí para hablar
de Valentina La escudería Red Bull
consiguió el primer Triunfo de la
temporada está la escudería austriaca
muy por encima del resto y lo que vimos
este domingo fue un preámbulo de lo que
será la temporada 2023
Sí claro creo que todos nos quedamos con
esa sensación de que Red Bull pues es la
escudería más dominante y que
lastimosamente puede presentarse un
panorama muy parecido al que tuvimos en
la segunda parte de la temporada pasada
en la cual pues Red Bull arrasó
totalmente con lo que fue verstappen y
pues checo que tuvo una que otra
oportunidad como por ejemplo en Singapur
pero hay que tener un tema hay un tema
que hay que tener en cuenta y es el tema
del túnel de viento porque recordemos
que Red Bull tiene limitadas las horas
de Túnel de viento por haber excedido el
límite presupuestario el año pasado y
esto podría de pronto llegar a ser un
obstáculo en el desarrollo del auto del
coche que es algo muy importante y tal
vez esto podría permitir que más
adelante en algunas carreras de pronto
después del receso de verano podamos
tener a Aston Martin Mercedes Ferrari
acercándose un poco más sin embargo la
diferencia es muy amplia y por más de
que puedan tener esa desventaja Parece
que pues va a ser un año de dominio
total al menos en términos del
Campeonato de constructores y de pilotos
seguramente también
Valentina pero hablemos de Ferrari
porque días atrás este escudería
anunciaba que el francés Frederick basur
asumía como director deportivo en lugar
de Matías pinotto quien ahora ejerce
otro cargo dentro de la planta en
maranelo y el equipo indicaba que un
problemas de estrategia En la temporada
pasada lo que vimos hoy fue una mala
estrategia o hay problemas más graves en
el auto que le impiden aferrar y
pelearle a Red Bull
no pero a mí no es un tema de estrategia
para mí hay problemas más de fondo y los
vimos desde la pretemporada también en
bahré y es el tema de la degradación de
los neumáticos que está haciendo crítico
para Ferrari es un tema que incluso no
ha sido solo crítico para Ferrari sino
por ejemplo hoy nos sorprendió que
también fue crítico para Mercedes y esto
es algo que los afecta mucho en ritmo de
carrera y es algo que también habían
sufrido en 2022 aparte de esos múltiples
problemas que habían tenido estrategia
etcétera etcétera sufrían mucho con las
gomas en comparación a Red Bull y esto
los termina afectando eventualmente en
el ritmo de carrera y es algo que se
nota por ejemplo la diferencia con Aston
Martin incluso Entonces el tema de la
degradación de las gomas es algo que los
está afectando y hoy pudimos ver
nuevamente un tema que también vivimos
la temporada pasada y que es una
constante que va más allá de esa
estrategia y es la fiabilidad del auto
que es muy importante no se vale
únicamente tener un buen coche sino que
necesitas que sea fiable y tuvimos el
motor de leclerc que pues no pudo
terminar la carrera se vio obligado a
abandonar el tema también de electrónica
recordemos que el leclerc cambió la
centralita electrónica antes de la
carrera antes de la primera carrera ya
utilizar la segunda cuando se permiten
máximo dos en el año obviamente pues por
un tema de precaución pero todo este
tema de la fiabilidad Parece que va a
volver a ser un problema en la escudería
Ferrari y eso son aspectos que van más
allá de la estrategia Y ese tema que
vimos la temporada pasada pero hablemos
ahora de Fernando Alonso la noticia
agradable de la jornada ya que consiguió
su primer podio desde el año 2021 Alonso
y Aston Martin su nueva escudería han
sido cautelosos con las emociones a lo
largo del fin de semana por los
resultados que obtuvieron pero podríamos
estar viendo el surgimiento de este
escudería o los resultados alcanzados
este fin de semana no son más que un
producto del inicio de la temporada
donde los equipos Todavía siguen
afinando sus monoplazas
no yo creo que surgimiento a Dios Eso no
tiene que comparar los equipos con lo
que eran el año pasado y si comparamos
el Aston Martin del año pasado que
estaba peleando por ser séptimo en el
campeonato de constructores y lo
comparamos con este que está peleando
por el podio y consigue podio en la
primera carrera de la temporada
eventualmente hay una mejoría de hecho
decía Carlos Sainz que los rumores
venían desde diciembre del año pasado de
que había una mejora en Aston Martin y
él lo decía cuando hay tantos rumores
algo tiene que algo tiene que haber
desierto y efectivamente Pues hay una
Mejora y pueden estar en esa pelea con
lo que es Mercedes y Ferrari por ser la
escudería detrás de Red Bull no que creo
que es algo que todos le están apuntando
a un igualar La Red Bull y decir que
Fernando Alonso va a pelear por el
Campeonato pues es un poco descabellado
es un poco difícil con el panorama que
tenemos hoy en día pero el hecho de que
esté peleando por el podio que
claramente se vio influenciado por el
retiro de leclerc pero que haya tenido
ese ritmo que haya tenido esa
conservación de los neumáticos que fue
muy importante es algo a destacar y que
definitivamente dice que Aston Martin va
a estar en la pelea aparte de un aspecto
no menor recordemos que en 2021 Hubo
mucho pleito porque Aston Martin se
llevó uno de los jefes pues más
importantes en términos de diseño y
aerodinámica de Red Ball que es dan
falos Este es el primer auto diseñado
por él y definitivamente se nota la mano
una persona con experiencia que llegó a
aportar muchísimo y que les está
permitiendo tener un concepto muy
interesante La pregunta es van a poder
mantenerse en ese nivel toda la
temporada es muy pronto para decirlo
pero esperemos que las mejoras puedan ir
encaminadas hacia un buen lado y con lo
que comentábamos antes que tal vez no va
a tener la oportunidad de tener tantas
mejoras por el tema del túnel de viento
ahí hasta el Martin pues puede
aprovechar